[Aplausos]
en 2018 pasé cinco meses recogiendo
basura recogiendo tal 711 kilos siendo
el 90% plástico para que os hagáis una
idea para generar todos esos kilos de
plástico se necesitan 1.4 toneladas de
petróleo y más de 4 veces la energía que
gasta una familia en un año
probablemente os estaréis preguntando
por qué por qué alguien de 27 años
decide poner su vida en pausa durante 5
meses para recoger basura pudiendo
dedicar ese tiempo a viajar por el
sudeste asiático hacer carrera en una
empresa y ganar dinero o ver 15 veces
seguidas todas las temporadas de los
simpsons con sus más de 600 episodios
pues bueno la verdad es que lo podría
haber hecho o por gusto pero os puedo
asegurar que no tengo ni síndrome de
diógenes ni ninguna filial rara con la
basura también lo podría haber hecho por
dinero pero lo cierto es que durante
esos cinco meses recogiendo basura no
ingresé ni un solo euro por hacerlo lo
hice porque pensé que era la mejor forma
de luchar por una causa luchar contra
una situación de injusticia que está
viviendo nuestro planeta y que en mi
opinión necesita ser cambiada
para poneros un poquito en contexto
dejadme que os cuente algo sobre mí hay
dos cosas que me encantan en la vida por
las cuales me plantearía hasta vender mi
alma al la primera es el
guacamole
y la segunda son los viajes de aventura
dejar con mi bici con mi kayak acampar
bajo las estrellas con el guacamole
acampando bajo las estrellas eso ya para
mí la verdad es que es insuperable lo
que me pasaba en mis viajes de aventura
era que yo no paraba de ver basura y eso
hacía que yo no pudiese disfrutar tanto
del sitio en el que me encontraba
la idea de pasar tres que al final
fueron cinco meses recogiendo basura
surgió viajando y más en concreto
viajando solo que es cuando más abiertos
estamos a nuevas ideas nuevos
pensamientos nuevos cambios nuevas
personas estaba dando la vuelta a la
isla de ibiza en kayak en solitario me
desperté en cala saladeta y me acerqué a
la orilla a pegarme el primer baño de la
mañana ahí me encontré con los restos de
los vasos de plástico y las pajitas de
los mojitos que los turistas habían
dejado el día anterior
ayude a un hombre a recoger todo eso que
me dijo muy preocupado que lo limpia
vamos entre él y yo o todo eso y va
acabar en el mar también me dijo que
llevaba más de 20 años yendo a veranear
a ibiza y que nunca repito nunca la
había visto tan sucia
recogimos la playa y nos despedimos yo
continué mi travesía en kayak y remando
y pensando y pensando y remando me dije
a mí mismo que quería hacer algo más que
iba a limpiar la siguiente playa en la
que fuese a dormir por la tarde recogí
cullen trisca en 25 minutos llene cinco
bolsas grandes de basura con la
satisfacción del trabajo bien hecho me
dispuse a relajarme un poco conocer el
fondo marino y cuando me puse a bucear
me di cuenta de que en el fondo del mar
había más del doble plástico del que yo
había sido capaz de recoger en la orilla
en ese momento volvió a mi cabeza
aquella frase que ese hombre había dicho
por la mañana al final todo acaba en el
mar ahí pensé que igual había algo más
que yo podría hacer por dar visibilidad
a esta causa y concienciar a la gente
hasta la fecha yo estaba haciendo un
poco lo que hacemos todos con las causas
que nos importan aprendía sobre el tema
leía artículos veía documentales los
compartía en redes sociales firmaba
peticiones en change.org todo esto está
fenomenal pero yo tenía la sensación de
que había algo más que podía hacer por
dar visibilidad este problema
medioambiental que estamos viviendo al
volver de ibiza a valència monte el
proyecto mis pachamama la pachamama es
la diosa inca de la naturaleza y me
pareció un homenaje bonito ponerle este
nombre al proyecto a partir de ahí
durante cinco meses y a lomos de mi
bicicleta y la vuelta a españa
recogiendo basura y documentando lo todo
en las redes sociales el 14 de julio
salí de valència y me fui a teruel de
ella zaragoza
tudela pamplona san sebastián todo el
norte hasta la coruña bajé galicia
santiago ourense zamora salamanca ávila
madrid toledo córdoba sevilla el parque
de doñana toda la costa andaluza hasta
almería murcia alicante y cinco meses
después volví a estar en el mismo sitio
del que había salido las torres de
serrano de valència
mil 546 kilómetros entre mis piernas y
711 kilos de basura recogidos
antes de salir hubo gente que me dijo y
rafa vas a montar un proyecto de
concienciación tú solo te va a ser una
aventura tan larga sin compañía vas a
renunciar a un sueldo a final de mes o
vas a cambiar tu piso por una tienda de
campaña tantos meses y la verdad es que
si en mi cabeza estaba claro yo quería
concienciar a todo el que pudiera sobre
el consumo de plástico que hacemos en el
día a día y cómo éste afecta a nuestra
naturaleza
yo sabía que yo solo no iba a ser capaz
de cambiar las cosas pero pensé que yo
al igual que cada uno de vosotros que
estáis en esta sala escuchando era capaz
de concienciar a cientos quizás a miles
de personas y que entre todos
consiguiésemos cambiar la situación
y claro que no ha sido fácil claro que
han habido obstáculos los mismos
obstáculos que podéis vivir vosotros si
un día decidimos montar un proyecto que
busque un cambio en la sociedad
yo lo que quiero en esta charla es
contaros qué cosas positivas saqué de
aquellos momentos duros porque lo que os
puedo asegurar es que dedicar vuestra
energía y vuestro tiempo aquella causa
que tanto os importa merece muchísimo la
pena yo tengo mi causa clara el consumo
de plástico que hacemos y cómo éste
afecta a la salud de nuestra naturaleza
es posible que vosotros tengáis otra
causa ya sea la situación actual del
sistema educativo el empoderamiento de
la mujer la desaparición del del oso
polar o dar visibilidad a una enfermedad
rara hay cientos miles de causas con las
que merece la pena involucrarse y ya va
a depender de nuestros intereses
nuestros gustos circunstancias vividas o
experiencias que nos identifiquemos más
con unas que con otras
el primer problema al que yo me enfrenté
al montar un proyecto que busca un
cambio fue el tema económico porque es
cómodo es muy cómodo recibir un sueldo a
final de mes en nuestra cuenta del banco
pero yo tenía la sensación de que a mis
40 horas de trabajo semanales les
faltaba intención un propósito
dedicarlas a algo que hiciesen de este
planeta un lugar un poquito mejor y no
me quiero poner en plan catastrofista
luego tenía un buen trabajo en una
empresa que me gustaba una excelente
relación con mis jefes compañeros a los
que llamó amigos pero no acababa de
sentirme del todo realizado
la verdad es que me podría haber quedado
trabajando y haber donado parte de mi
sueldo a una entidad que trabajase por
la protección de la naturaleza pero
pensé que eso no era lo que el planeta
necesitaba en materia medioambiental no
necesitaba mi dinero necesitaba un
cambio de actitud un cambio de hábitos
en el consumo de plástico por parte de
cada uno de nosotros en el día a día no
estoy en contra de las donaciones no os
confundáis pero pienso que solo con
dinero no vamos a conseguir ganar esta
batalla por el cambio climático y la
preservación de la naturaleza
si yo buscaba un cambio de hábitos y yo
quería cambiar las cosas lo que tenía
que hacer era demostrarle a la gente la
situación en la que se encontraba la
naturaleza y como con nuestras pequeñas
acciones diarias podíamos revertir la
mostrar que podemos vivir comprando a
granel sin necesidad de utilizar todos
esos plásticos con los que las empresas
envuelven los productos que nos venden
que podemos vivir comprando y utilizando
productos de higiene personal sin
plástico los beneficios de llevar
nuestras propias botellas de agua en vez
de estar constantemente comprando
botellas de agua mineral en plástico en
definitiva que podemos vivir de una
forma mucho más sostenible sin que esto
suponga un grandísimo problema la verdad
es que ahora ingreso bastante menos
dinero que antes sin embargo tengo una
vida que me llena mucho más
dedico mis horas a aquello que me gusta
y se me han abierto oportunidades super
bonitas que jamás me hubiese imaginado
desde la mesa mi oficina oportunidades
como estar hoy aquí hablando con
vosotros o que me llamen de college de
toda españa porque quieren que hable con
los niños sobre temas medioambientales
también darme cuenta de que no necesito
tanto dinero como yo creía para vivir me
ha animado a emprender algo que siempre
me haya hecho muchísima ilusión pero que
nunca me había atrevido por la
incertidumbre económica que esto genera
el segundo problema al que me enfrenté
igual los pasa a vosotros también si
decidís montar un proyecto estas
características fue renunciar a ciertas
comodidades comodidades que muchas veces
nos han impuesto y ni siquiera nos
planteamos si realmente las necesitamos
o no en mi caso en su momento renuncie a
un apartamento para mí solo a una
empresa en la que hacer carrera renuncié
a salir a cenar siempre que quiera algún
abono para el gimnasio o tener fibra
internet de la máxima velocidad en casa
trabajar por mantener estas comodidades
hacía que yo no me pudiese centrar en
aquellas cosas que realmente me importan
me mueven por dentro en los cinco meses
que estuve viajando en bicicleta vivido
una forma muy sencilla haciendo acampada
libre y alimentando me a base de arroz
blanco comprado a granel y botes de
garbanzos con lo justo que cabe en un
par de alforjas un par de zapatillas
unas chanclas un pantalón corto uno
largo tres camisetas una camisa tres
pares de calcetines tres calzoncillos
algo de abrigo saco de dormir esterillas
tienda de campaña y bolsa de aseo sino
un piso para mí solo sino una empresa
que hacer carrera sin salir a cenar sin
un abono para ir al gimnasio o sin
tarifa 'internet en casa
sin embargo gracias a reducir mi vida y
vivir de una forma sencilla me he podido
centrar en cosas como hacer muchísimo
deporte pasar muchas horas en la
naturaleza conocer a gente nueva y sobre
todo conciencia sobre el consumo de
plástico que hacemos y cómo éste afecta
a nuestra naturaleza
lo tercero que os puede pasar si decidís
montar un proyecto que busca remover
conciencias y un cambio en la sociedad
es enfrentaros a la soledad sentidos
solos en algunos momentos es posible que
renuncies al apoyo y el respaldo
constante de nuestro entorno o parte de
la sociedad ya sea en un sentido físico
o en un sentido emocional porque no
entienden parte de los cambios que
estáis poniendo en vuestra vida en mi
caso por suerte fue en un sentido físico
y aquello siempre he contado con el
apoyo total de mis padres y de mi
hermana pero sí que es verdad que he
pasado muchas horas solo sin embargo he
sacado cosas positivas de esto he tenido
mucho tiempo para pensar aunque suene a
cliché me he conocido más a mí mismo y
esto también me ha dado confianza pero
no son solo beneficios para con uno
mismo yo también creo que me he sentido
más conectado a mi familia que antes
probablemente ha hablado más con ellos
en estos cinco meses que en los que
monté el proyecto que en todo el año
anterior he descubierto la cara más
humana de amigos de toda la vida que
jamás me hubiese imaginado que se iban a
identificar con una causa medioambiental
y que se han unido al proyecto
recogiendo basura he retomado el
contacto con compañeros de colegio que
hacía más
años que no sabía nada de ellos y que me
han escrito para decirme que les gustaba
lo que veían en redes sociales que
estaba haciendo y que ellos ahora
también recogían basura
he conocido a gente nueva con los mismos
intereses e inquietudes que tengo yo no
sé si a vosotros os pasa pero a mí por
lo menos conforme más mayor me hago más
me cuesta hacer amigos nuevos y este
cambio de aires y montar el proyecto ha
traído gente nueva a mi vida si me
dejáis que os dé un pequeñito consejo si
lo que se está frenando o si lo que os
está parando a la hora de montar un
proyecto que busca un cambio en la
sociedad es la soledad os diría que no
le tuvieseis miedo porque por un lado
aprenderéis a conocer os más a vosotros
mismos y por el otro estaréis más
abiertos a que entre gente nueva en
vuestra vida que aportará muchísimo
por último os quiero hablar de esos
momentos duros en los que te desplomas
porque no nos engañemos montar un
proyecto que busca remover conciencias y
un cambio en la sociedad es una montaña
rusa de emociones están los días en los
que estás pletórico y parece que te vas
a comer el mundo luego están los días en
los que no lo ves tan claro como aquel
día en asturias en la playa del aguilar
en el que recogí envases de plástico en
perfecto estado 20 años después con
fecha de consumo preferente de agosto
del 97 y dude de sí lo que yo estaba
haciendo realmente la capaz de conseguir
un cambio
y luego está el día es en el que te
desplomas en el que no sabes si te vas a
volver a levantar si merece la pena
seguir luchando por esa causa con la que
te has comprometido yo recuerdo
perfectamente los momentos más duros
desde que monté el proyecto mis
pachamama estaba saliendo de madrid más
en concreto de las rozas había dormido
en casa de mi amigo luís y llevaba desde
las 12 durante una hora y media
pedaleando por un camino de tierra
dirección toledo de repente me entró el
dolor de cabeza el pinchazo más fuerte
que he sentido nunca me bajé la bici
algo mareado y me aparte a un lado del
camino estaba asustado porque yo nunca
me pongo enfermo decidí tumbarme a
esperar a que se me pasase el dolor a
las 7 la tarde me desperté no había
pasado nadie por ese camino que me
pudiese ayudar y yo no tenía la fuerza
suficiente para llegar hasta el
siguiente pueblo que tenía una farmacia
entonces planté la tienda de campaña y
acampe hasta que la situación mejorase
la cosa se alargó más de lo que esperaba
estuve 36 horas acampado sin que pasase
nadie por aquel camino y sí que se me
pasase el dolor hasta que pasaron las 36
horas
porque me estaba quedando ya sin agua y
sin comida
durante todas esas horas allí dentro de
la tienda campaña en mi saco con este
dolor de cabeza pensé rafa allí y si
abandonas merece la pena estar aquí
pasándolo mal pudiendo estar en tu casa
en tu cama con un con un caldo de tu
madre y medicinas
y en ese momento me acordé de todo lo
que había vivido en la primera mitad del
proyecto toda la gente que había
conocido luna mikel christina javi forés
sergi fabio iván josé rocío carlos me
acordé de esas rutas preciosas que había
pedaleado de pamplona san sebastián por
el antiguo plazaola el cambio del país
vasco' a cantabria por las montañas a la
altura de castro urdiales me acordé de
esos proyectos que había conocido y que
tanto me habían inspirado como soy ciclo
viajera de iria que empodera a la mujer
para que viaje sola en bici o light
humanity de eugenio que lucha por una
energía limpia sostenible y accesible
para todo el mundo ahí me di cuenta de
que no estaba dispuesto a renunciar a
todo lo que me quedaba por vivir en la
segunda mitad los momentos duros son
efímeros pero lo que dejamos de vivir
eso no lo recuperamos nunca y menos mal
que decidí continuar porque de no
haberlo hecho me habría perdido
experiencias como empujar mi bici
totalmente a oscuras bajo las estrellas
con el ruido de los animales atravesando
el parque de doñana porque la arena no
no me dejaba pedalear una ruta
maravillosa de matalascañas sanlúcar
a 40 km con la marea baja pedaleando por
la arena a escasos centímetros del agua
me habría perdido conocer a gente como
raúl como mónica como édgar me habría
perdido enamorarme de tarifa de las
playas de granada visitar el cabo de
gata si me dejáis que os dé otro consejo
es que si decidís montar un proyecto que
busca un cambio en la sociedad y remover
conciencias o se enamore jce del proceso
de montarlo porque cuando vengan los
momentos duros que vendrán y nuestra
mente nos intente traicionar y ponga a
prueba nuestra fortaleza mental en lo
único en lo que nos vamos a poder para
apoyar para continuar es en lo que hemos
vivido y en lo que nos queda por vivir
montar el proyecto mis pachamama es la
mejor decisión que he tomado en mi vida
y no cambio ni el dinero que he dejado
de ganar ni renunciar a ciertas
comodidades ni la soledad ni los
momentos duros por todo lo vivido todo
lo conocido toda esa gente que he puesto
en mi vida y todos esos mensajes de
gente que me ha escrito para decirme que
desde que ve lo que hago consume menos
plástico y cuida más el planeta supongo
estaréis preguntando y ahora que te
haces con tu vida ralph así si ha
acabado el viaje bueno el proyecto mis
pachamama continúa yo sigo viviendo de
una forma sencilla
y dedico mis horas a aquello que me
gusta estoy montando ya la siguiente
aventura este verano recorrer en la
transpirenaica
estos son los 800 kilómetros andando a
través de los pirineos que unen el mar
mediterráneo con el mar cantábrico dando
visibilidad a este problema
medioambiental que tenemos educando
sobre cómo podemos vivir utilizando
menos plástico y pasando a la acción
recogiendo aquella basura que encuentra
me pasó muchas gracias por la sombra
[Aplausos]